when people think of hasidism or the
hasidic movement they usually conjure up
images of men in black hats and clothing
and very strict religious practice
the
sometimes called ultra orthodox jews are
featured in netflix series in movies etc
and are as i said associated with very
strict and and conservative you could
say religious practices what many people
don't know is that the hasidic movement
is also a deeply mystical tradition
steeped in the tradition of kabbalah and
other forms of jewish mysticism this is
a very broad topic and the hasidic
movement is of course a lot more complex
than what i have described just now but
in this video we will be focusing on
exploring the earliest developments and
in the origins of the hasidic movements
its practices its theological and
metaphysical ideas and what
characterizes it as well as discussing
of course the founder you could say of
this moment who was one of the most
fascinating figures in the history of
judaism
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
shaman peripatetic healer soothsayer
heretic jewish holy man these are all
labels that have at one point or another
been attached to rabbi israel ben elizer
also known as the baal shem tov or
simply the best the name baal shem tov
means master of the good name and the
title balchem was given to certain
people who used prayers incantations
herbs and other techniques that some
might call magical or quasi-magical most
people don't associate such notions to
jewish practice but history and reality
is of course more complex than that and
in this sense the best was not all that
unique what was unique was how well he
caught on with his community and the
movement known as khasidism that he
jumpstarted a movement that is still
huge in the jewish world today and is
even growing now hazardism today looks
quite different from the hasidism of the
18th century when it originated and
there aren't many aspects of the vast
literature of hasidic thoughts that are
truly set in stone doctrines
as with many other observant jewish
communities debate and study feature
prominently though in its earliest
stages not as prominently as the
surrounding community so to outline just
one fixed form of quote-unquote hasidism
would give us a very narrow view which
doesn't really correspond to to
well reality
also each hasidic master has expounded
his own thoughts on a variety of topics
and introduce new and dynamic ideas and
scholars still hotly debate the
characterization of the movement in
general therefore it would probably be
an impossible task to appease everybody
with this episode but i will try to
highlight some of the characteristic
features of early hasidism as
represented by the baal shem tov and his
immediate successors
born probably in 1698 in the small
backwater town of occupy in what was
then podolia which is now
southwestern ukraine the balshem tov was
not set up for success in the jewish
world no great rabbis or scholar lived
near him as i mentioned he wasn't that
notable of a figure and in fact his
early life is shrouded in relative
mystery
what we do know is that sometime in the
1730s the best embarked on a spiritual
retreat in the carpathian mountains
working as something called a line
digger and during this time he is also
said to have had some significant
spiritual experiences when he returned
he settled in the village of mitsubishi
the village with which he would become
more strongly associated he seems to
have been received quite well there
garnering a large following and even
coming to be employed by the town as a
kind of residential capitalist if you
don't remember or haven't watched my
earlier episodes on the kabbalah the
kabbalah is a form of jewish mysticism
that emerged primarily in iberia and in
southern france in the middle ages
associated with literary works like the
zohar very famously and by the time of
the baal shem tov and his life kabbalah
was
deeply intertwined with all of religious
thought and practice and had been so for
a couple of centuries at that point and
indeed this is very important to
remember that the baal shem tov and the
hasidic movement in general comes out of
this kabbalistic environment and and
very
deeply
steeped in the tradition of kabbalah and
jewish mysticism as the sort of in-house
catalyst in matsubish the balshem tobe
had his own minyan a group of 10
followers which was required to hold a
prayer service and he was paid a salary
it was from this position that he came
to touch the hearts and souls of his
disciples garnering modest but
enthusiastic support from devoted pupils
hailing from other parts of podolia
galatia russia and other areas this is
significant of course but it wasn't
until the generations following his
death that the bash's teachings would
explode into the multinational movement
that made it famous as is sometimes the
case with people like him the baal shem
tov didn't produce many writings of his
own he transmitted orally his parables
and homilies both trademark forms of
hasidic interpretation it was his
disciples perhaps most notably rabbi
yaakov youssef of polnoy
that gave us clear recordings of rabbi
israel's teachings through these largely
second-hand sources we get a picture of
the besht's thought while very
innovative in certain areas it is deeply
steeped in a background of lurianic
kabbalah a form of kabbalah developed by
the thinker yitzhak luria in the 16th
century
an understanding of that background and
of that kind of kabbalah is kind of
necessary to grasp the complexities of
the balsham tov's mystical ideas and
endeavor the best borrowed from luria a
dynamic understanding of the spheroids
or emanations of the divine as well as
the concept of divine sparks hidden
inside the shells or vessels
he greatly adapted luria's understanding
of the sin sum or the divine contraction
that is when the insof or the infinite
so the ainsof is a common name for
god the absolute form of god in kabbalah
and this
word ainsof means the infinite and in
luriana kabbalah there is this very
famous idea of the tsimsum which means
contraction that when when the ainsworth
when god in his absolute form wants to
create something he has to contract
within himself right he has to create a
space within his infinite nature in
which
the world is created where he can sort
of emanate the light that becomes
eventually the created worlds and
different thinkers including the baal
shem tov have interpreted this idea of
tim tsum differently of course but
still is a very central and important
part of lurianic kabbalah that is also
very
prominent in the hasidic movements and
their metaphysical ideas he and his
disciples also in some regard adopted
the concept of gilgal or reincarnation
in his messianic ideas along with many
other important lyrianic innovations
two of the main themes associated with
bastian and hasidic theology is what we
could call an imminentist conception of
god as well as a kind of monistic
cosmology to the baal shem tov god was
not this transcendent otherworldly being
that many other jews conceived of
instead god or more specifically the
shrina what professor shall maggot
called the divine indwelling in nature
was present in the world
the shrina is usually conceived of as
the last of the ten spherot as well as a
kind of divine feminine principle but
what we see in early hasidic literature
is a sort of blurring of the harsh
dividing lines between different spherot
on the one hand and parts of the godhead
now mapping out this cosmic realm while
hugely important to medieval capitalists
and dogma to traditional eastern
european jews of the 18th century was
not nearly as important to the balshem
tov as
experiencing the divine for the khasid
god is not apart or holy transcendent
from us but with us quote one must
always think that the creator fills the
earth with his glory one should consider
that when he looks at physical things it
is as if he is beholding the
which is within him here in a sense god
is paradoxically both transcendent and
imminent his infinitude does not just
mean he's way out there in the
traditional transcendent conception god
is not only the whole of the universe
encapsulating it and all the other
worlds out there but here as well within
everything and within us
this personalized inner quality of god
is perhaps as we will see later the most
important notion that the baal shem tov
brings to the fore such an
all-encompassing idea of divine
imminence is central to hasidic theology
it has often been labeled pan and
theistic a concept meaning all in god so
sort of a
qualified version of pantheism all is
god
rabbi shnoor zalman of liadi the founder
of the khabad movement which is its own
big sub movement within hasidism takes
this idea even a step further than the
best in writing that quote his very
essence and being may he be blessed
which is called by the name einstoff
completely fills the earth both in space
and in time everything is filled with
the light of the insolve now in
traditional kabbalah as i said insofa is
usually characterized as a hidden
unknowable god that is
somehow apart and transcendent from our
world and that actually contracts out
or contracts
a space outside of himself in this
process known as timsum this is one
interpretation at least here however
rabbi schneer solman is claiming that
this unknowable god that we cannot
perceive or even really talk about is
here in our world instead of a physical
symptom or contraction out of the world
what scholars call an ontological
conception of the process schneer zalman
gives us an epistemological conception
his idea of tim tom is in the words of
alan nadler called a deliberate act of
self-eclipse or concealment from human
consciousness rather than an actual
delimitation or contraction of the
divine essence and spirit per se
us humans cannot fully grasp or fathom
the glory and essence of the ain't serve
so he delimited himself in stages
emanating these sphero that become less
and less hidden or hard to fathom each
time dove bed of matsurish also called
the market of mercedes the great margin
or simply marget and probably the best
most important disciple gives a similar
idea of tim tom as a process of ainsurf
lessening its complexity so that we can
understand it
the laws of the torah becomes a sort of
simple guidebook to steer us in the
right direction since we can't actually
grasp the god itself in the form of
ainsof in its absolute form so to say in
any case it is clear that instead of the
harsh distinction between the profane
world that we live in and the divine
world of the godhead which arguably
characterizes much of
lyrianic kabbalah otherwise the baal
shem tov sees god as being
here present in our world in a very
profound and direct sense and that this
god can actually be reached this
imminent god can be reached through
certain spiritual exercises this is
where perhaps the most important hasidic
concept comes into play the idea of
devakut the word is usually translated
as cleaving to god or union or communion
with god and it has a wide range of uses
in the hasidic and even just the bastian
literature
for the baal shem tov de vekut is a
deeply personal experience one cleaves
to god by moving inward and cultivating
what the best calls inner awe through
certain spiritual exercises and forms of
prayer the idea of cleaving to god or
devakut of ascending through the cosmos
and interacting with higher spheros is
not unique to the best of course neither
is the idea of moving upwards through
the four worlds or hola mode it is the
way the best proposes one ascends
through these worlds who is allowed to
do it and the prominence in the primary
place that it takes in his general
practice that is indeed revolutionary
and that did become a point of major
contention for many jews at the time
first we have to consider that the best
contemplative and prayer-based practices
form the backbone of debit codes
however he doesn't have a comprehensive
handbook on the topic but rather a
series of shorter teachings that have
been collected from throughout his life
a major part of the bahasa spiritual
practice is the process of making
or unifications
there are generally three yehudim and
with each one the practitioner rises to
a new olam or world menachem
outlines the altered state of
consciousness one achieves with each
quote the first involves contemplative
awareness of the integral relationship
of everything that exists within
manifest creation
all beings human and animal all life
forms including the ignorant making a
yehud means not only recognizing how all
things are interconnected but
specifically including oneself within
that web of manifest existence
from this gross level of integration one
proceeds to ascend to enter more deeply
into contemplative awareness of nishamut
this level involves imaginal or angelic
forces and powers as well as other souls
that may appear within one's own
consciousness at a subtle level one must
then ascend to the level of recognition
of elohuth as the causal itself here one
encounters and integrates the highest
spheres or swerot they are located at
the very deepest levels of
manifestations accessible to human
consciousness effectively integrated
within divinity itself making yechudim
however is not simply a contemplative
practice the practitioner prays very
slowly paying attention to his breath
while visualizing a quote flow of
spiritual empowerment
it is said that the best prayed so
slowly and for so long that his
disciples often could not stand it and
would walk out of the synagogue in
exhaustion
devicuts however is not just meant for
powerful heavy spiritual experiences
one can and indeed should try to
integrate or experience divakute on a
daily or everyday basis even throughout
the day while performing normal
activities one can contemplate the
shrina and the torah quotes even when
talking to people bear in mind that the
22 letters that constitute the means of
common speech are ultimately the
substratum of the torah the barshem 12
also insists that even though one may be
in a state of constricted consciousness
known as katemoth
where one can't fully focus on the
divine one can still achieve the vakuts
even in this state
he writes quote
when one is in constricted consciousness
it should also be with adherence to the
shrina
so contemplating the shrina or the torah
is also a kind of device although a
smaller one compared to the very
dramatic
way of making
that i described just previously much
like abraham abulafia who i've already
made an episode about the best even
speaks of reaching devakut by focusing
on hebrew letters one focuses on the
core the sort of inner meanings of these
letters contemplating them and
understanding not just their external
aspects but their essence the spherot
with which they have connections and
other lessons that can be drawn from
them what the baal shem tov hoped to
draw from these exercises was an
authentic devotion to god and to the
mitzvot the commandments of god in the
torah or the jewish law indeed the word
khasid means pious and the baal shem tov
took his commitment to piety very
seriously authentic prayer true inner
piety and a yearning for profound
mystical experience are paramount to
hasidic practice
the best cared about the genuineness of
prayer not just going through the
motions as such if you truly have a fear
of god you can commune with god himself
you don't pray because it will help you
in the community or because you think it
will result in some sort of financial
gain or whatever you do it quote because
of his omnipotent rule the upshot of
this commitment to genuineness in prayer
was a lessening commitment to the
traditional formalities of the prayer
service the hasidim introduced a new
model of prayer centered on the stibul a
small center of worship that featured
lively prayer
as well as very ecstatic
exclamations and experiences the
khasidim's focus on inner authenticity
and spiritual ascendance however
did run counter to the
core of what we could call
traditional quote-unquote judaism at the
time
which was a strict studying of the torah
now that isn't to say that the baal shem
tov didn't consider studying the torah
to be a central part of judaism of
course he did and he integrated this
into the well became the hasidic
movement as well of course but it
doesn't have you could say the same
primacy it's not as emphasized in the
hasidic movements as it was for some
other jews at the time and it wasn't
just the baal shem tov's emphasis on
devekut rather than intense study that
angered many other jewish authorities
but also his ideas about who could
achieve this now traditionally the
kabbalah and mystical experiences were
kind of reserved for the very elite
intelligentsia or the elite scholars
there
it is said that traditionally to study
the kabbalah you had to be 40 years old
you had to be married and have children
you had to know the entire torah and
talmud there were many
restrictions on who could even begin to
study the kabbalah
and so the baal shem tov's idea is that
anyone can reach devote in other words
anyone can reach this experience of
cleaving or uniting with god
that was quite a new idea at this time
this democratization of kabbalistic
practice
was quite
shocking of course and could in a way
disrupt the entire social structure of
judaism as such at the time we must be
clear however that the baal shem tov
certainly did not espouse a total
spiritual egalitarianism
far from it actually he claimed to be on
a higher spiritual plane and therefore
uniquely capable of deep mystical
experience
this idea continued in the generation
following the besht's death through the
idea of this sadiq or the righteous one
these sadiquim were seen as being more
spiritually evolved and served as
leaders thus an alternate power
structure kind of emerged based not on
intelligence and devotion to study but
on spirits and charisma
this too threatened the traditional
community and its social structure
during the life of the baltimore himself
however this was not that much of a
threat to the jewish community as such
since the hasidic movement at this time
was quite a small
affair it garnered followers here and
there but did not really have any kind
of central authority other than the baal
shem tov himself the baal shem tov died
in 1760 and it was only in the
generations following his death that the
hasidic movement really started to gain
some ground the basham tells closest
disciples with significant figures like
jacob yosef of ponoy d'or bear the
margaret of mesrich and pinchas shapiro
of cortez ushered the new hasidic
movement into a new era and helped it
spread across eastern europe in fact the
movement exploded across europe
capturing the hearts and minds of many
especially younger jews
despite its many radical innovations
khasidism was sort of just accepted or
at least tolerated in most places but in
lithuania the story was very different
some of the jewish authorities in
lithuania specifically a man named
elijah ben solomon zalman better known
as the vil nagaon launched a vicious
multi-year attack against the khasidim
the gown wrote a series of polemics
throughout the latter part of the 18th
century directed against the encroaching
hasidim in one he writes quote the
stubborn hearts insist on rejecting good
and choosing evil transgressing the
torah and changing its laws
in the torah of moses they have
established a new covenant working out
their evil schemes with the masses in
the house of the lord interpreting the
torah falsely while claiming that their
way is precious in the eyes of god they
call themselves khasidim that is an
abomination
how they have deceived this generation
uttering these words on high these are
thy gods of israel every stick and stone
clearly there's a lot of exaggeration
here he's writing polemically he is
clearly as i usually say in this episode
he's not a fan of the hasidim and thus
he writes these kinds of things as we've
seen the hasidim did not deny the
importance of the torah they held the
torah as a very central part of
religious practice just like every other
jew but it shows that there was some
kind of tension especially in lithuania
apparently about the hasidic movement
there was a fear that the hasidim were
secret practitioners of sabatianism a
17th century jewish messianic movement
centered on the figure of shabtsvi that
led many jewish to break certain laws of
the torah in hopes of redemption if you
don't know about shabtai sv
he was a
jewish figure who claimed to be the
messiah
in the 17th century and actually managed
to get probably the majority of jews
around the world to believe that he was
indeed the messiah and started this
massive movement
until suddenly one day he converts to
islam which completely
was a bombshell in the entire community
and when we look at the hasidic
movements and its appearance in europe
we also have to see it in the light of
the aftermath of this massive event this
was a traumatic event for the jewish
world at the time and the hasidic
movements kind of emerges as a not
necessarily as a response to it but
definitely as a result
partly of the environment that that
trauma kind of created you would think
that these worries from some of the
other jewish authorities came from
perhaps the
khasidim's use of lyrianic kabbalistic
ideas
but indeed when we look at for example
the gowans who wrote the polemical quote
that i just
read to you
he was also actually devoted capitalist
and when we look deeper we can see that
the theological
differences between the khasidim and its
enemies so to say
weren't really
that major at all the situation was a
lot more complex than that allah nader
writes that quote there was virtually no
substantive theological difference
between
in their respective theoretical
understandings of the nature of divine
imminence where they did differ was on
the place and application of this belief
in religious life and the propriety of
propagating it to the jewish masses thus
it was the practice the prayers and the
social organization that angered some
jewish authorities not theological
differences per se the tensions got so
bad that in 1771 when an epidemic hit
vilna causing the deaths of many of its
jewish citizens there were riots against
the khasidim they were blamed for this
epidemic they were some of them were
flogged and forced out of town despite
the gown's best efforts however the
hasidic movement spread far and wide new
hasidic masters developed their own
theologies and courts to which wide-eyed
students would flock for advice and
wisdom over the next few generations
these courts became true destinations
with communities forming around them and
their associated rebates or rabbis they
eventually came to follow a dynastic
model whereby a close relative of the
irabe would take over upon the former's
death this system is largely in place
today even though many hasidim have
moved to america or israel so what was
so appealing about the hasidic movement
to so many people around the world and
this is probably of course a complex
question to answer but one could guess
that at least
one aspect of its popularity stem from
the fact that it gave a more personal
relationship to god and one's religious
practice as well as a
relatively egalitarian attitude where
everyone was able to reach the most
deepest mystical experiences and
intimacy with god that did away with
some of the more hierarchical
structures that only allowed certain
elite people to have access to the
kabbalah and to the
what some consider as the deeper aspects
of the religion this instead allowed for
a wider
group of people to be
invited
to the secrets so to say of of of
jewish mysticism and then khasidism
in general or in particular i should say
one of the biggest contributions of
these movements are the twin ideas of
ayin and yesh often translated as
nothingness and suchness
ain is very similar to einstoff and in
fact ayin and ain are essentially the
same word
as einsof is an idea born out of a
negative theology in other words
explaining what god is through negations
one can't say anything about what god is
in a positive sense one can only
describe god but by what he isn't that
is that's what apathetic or what
negative theology means ain could be
described as a notion born from negative
ontology it is a sort of nothingness
that is necessary for yesh or creation
to occur
it pervades and links everything anyway
it is sort of like dark matter a
mysterious stand-in for what we can't
comprehend about the universe
ain is also however a goal it is
self-annihilation
to reach ain is in the markets
formulation a goal of devekut james
jacobson myself writes that quote one
who has achieved ayin has achieved
equanimity an indifference to the
vagaries of life and an absence of
self-concern
achieving ain means realizing both the
unity and equivalence of everything in
the world as well as its essential
non-value
as the margat himself teaches quotes a
person must consider himself nothing
they must abandon themselves and forget
their suffering in order to come to the
world of thought where everything is
equivalent this is not the case when he
is cleaving to the corporal reality of
this world
and quotes in both cases some including
the important scholar rivka schatz
offenheimer have used this concept to
claim that hasidism is at its core a
quietest movement focused primarily on
contemplation
the great scholar of jewish mysticism
gershom sholem went in a different
direction claiming that khasidism is
essentially world denying viewing our
life in a rather pessimistic light but
many scholars today have pushed back
against these conceptions including
james jacobs and maycells and moshe edel
claiming that hasidism and its specific
spiritual practices are in fact
activists and fundamentally world
affirming in this model hazardism calls
upon its adherence to find deeper
connections to the world and other
people and thereby also finding a deeper
connection with god
in this episode we have only discussed
the earliest developments and origins of
the hasidic movements some of its basic
theological
ideas and practices i'm doing this video
in collaboration with my good friend
zevi from the channel seekers of unity
he will be making a video releasing
today as well depending on when you're
watching of course but still he'll be
making a sister video to this one
which i know i've seen it it's
absolutely amazing you should watch that
zevi is a fantastic educator on youtube
and especially when it comes to this
subject he has a personal connection to
the hasidic movements having grown up in
this kind of environment
which i of course haven't so i
definitely encourage you to go watch his
video to see
a very thoroughly scholarly perspective
very
objective so to say as much as possible
but also very importantly from a kind of
inside perspective which i think is
always very valuable in these kinds of
discussions so
go watch zavi's video go subscribe to
his channel he's doing amazing work
i really love his channel and the videos
that he's putting out so i highly
recommend that after you've watched this
video of course
today the hasidic movement is a very
significant force in the jewish world
they exist in many parts around the
globe very famously for example in
israel of course but also in new york
the hasidic movements are often strongly
associated with the so-called ultra
orthodox or more properly called the
hadidim
which are very strictly observant jews
famous for some other
attire for example and these two terms
the hasidi or khasidim and the haredim
are sometimes synonymous even though
they of course aren't synonymous
completely but this shows you that the
the fact that the hasidic movement or
khasidism is a deeply mystical tradition
it is steeped in jewish mysticism and
kabbalah and yet it is very strict for
the most part in its conception and
practice of jewish law and
interpretation of the torah for example
it's another good example to show that
this very modern
nuagey kind of interpretation that
mysticism is
always some kind of liberal kind of
hippie
thing as opposed to strict religion when
in fact
for most of history that's basically the
opposite of the truth that mystics are
sometimes
more often some of the most strict
people in terms of religious practice
and in this case law for example we see
this in many other religions like islam
and christianity too with that said
there's of course a lot of nuance and
diversity here as well but i think
that's a
good point to keep in mind at the very
least in any case if you want to
understand judaism today you cannot do
so fully without also knowing about the
hasidic movements and in this episode i
have attempted to give you at least a
simple overview of the earliest
developments and ideas of this very
interesting jewish tradition it stands
as one of the most significant and
important
aspects of judaism in the world today
and is of course as i hope you will
agree at this point is very fascinating
and intriguing on various different
levels too
thank you for watching and i will see
you next time
thank you to seth weapon for writing
this episode and a special shout out as
always to all of my patrons who keep
this channel going thank you all so much
[Music]
you